A
IS GOOD FOR BOTH COUNTRIES.
LET'S TURN TO FREDERIK PLEITGEN
WHO JOINS US LIVE FROM MOSCOW.
GOOD TO SEE, FRED.
OVERALL, HOW DID THIS MEETING
BETWEEN BLANKET AND LAVROV GO,
AND WHAT MIGHT IT SIGNAL FOR A
POTENTIAL BIDEN PUTIN SUMMIT IN
THE COMING WEEKS?
>> TO THE POINT BIDEN SUMMIT,
WE HAVE HEARD THEY DIDN'T GO
INTO DETAILS ABOUT THAT, SUMMIT
ABOUT WHERE IT COULD, BE ABOUT
WHAT THE TOPICS COULD BE, AND
FIRST AND FOREMOST, ALSO, WHEN
THAT SUMMIT COULD HAPPEN, BUT
BOTH SIDES ARE SAYING THEY ARE
TRYING TO FLUSH THAT OUT.
BOTH SIDES, ROSEMARY, AGREED
THIS MEETING ACTUALLY WENT
QUITE WELL.
BETWEEN SERGEI LAVROV, AND
ANTHONY BLINKEN.
THE FIRST TIME THEY HAVE
ACTUALLY MET FACE TO FACE,
SINCE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CAME TO OFFICE.
BOTH SIDES MADE VERY CLEARLY
THERE ARE DEEP DISAGREEMENTS.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE SAYING
THAT U.S. WILL RESPOND IN AREAS
WHERE THE RUSSIANS ACT
AGGRESSIVELY.
THE RUSSIANS, FOR THEIR,
PRICING THEY BELIEVE THE U.S.
AND RUSSIA DISAGREE ON MANY
ISSUES, AND GEOPOLITICS BOTH
SIDES SAYING THAT THERE WOULD
BE A RESPONSE IF THE OTHER SIDE
DID SOMETHING THAT WAS AGAINST
THE NATIONAL INTEREST, WHERE
THE INTEREST OF EITHER THE U.S.
OR RUSSIA.
THAT ASIDE, BOTH SIDES DID SAY
THAT THEY WANTED THINGS TO
IMPROVE, AND JUDGING BY WHAT
THE RUSSIANS SAID LATER, WHAT
THEY SAID IN A READOUT LATER,
THEY SAID FOR INSTANCE
AFGHANISTAN A SITUATION THERE
WAS RAISED AND CREATE WAS
RAISED AND IRAN AND THOSE WERE
ALL ISSUES WHERE THE U.S. AND
RUSSIA BELIEVE THAT MAYBE THEY
COULD WORK TOGETHER AND MAKE
THINGS, AS BLINKEN SAID, MORE
PREDICTABLE.
THE MAIN REASON BOTH MEN ARE IN
REYKJAVIK, IN ICELAND, IS
BECAUSE TODAY, THERE IS THE
MINISTERIAL MEETING OF THE
ARCTIC COUNCIL.
THE ARCTIC IS CERTAINLY AN AREA
WHERE BOTH SIDES DO NOT AGREE
ON MANY THINGS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS THE
U.S. EXTREMELY CONCERNED AS
RUSSIA'S MILITARY BUILDUP IN
THE ARCTIC.
THE RUSSIANS MAKE NO SECRET
THAT BEING STRONG IN THE ARCTIC
MILITARILY IS A BIG PRIORITY
FOR THEM.
IN FACT THEY TOOK US TO ONE OF
THEIR MOST REMOTE BASIS WHICH
IS QUITE CLOSE TO NATO
TERRITORY AND SHOWED US HOW
STRONG THE MILITARY HAS BECOME.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE COURSE DUE NORTH, FLYING
FOR HOURS TO RUSSIA'S
NORTHERNMOST MILITARY
INSTALLATION.
MOSCOW GRANTED US A RARE VISIT
TO ITS BASE ON A BARREN
ARCHIPELAGO IN THE ARCTIC OCEAN,
WHICH RUSSIA BELIEVES IS KEY TO
DOMINATING THE ARCTIC.
>> THIS ENTIRE BASE IS COVERED
IN ICE, YET, THE RUSSIANS HAVE
MANAGED TO EXTEND THE RUNWAY TO
A POINT THAT THEY CAN LAND EVEN
THEIR HEAVIEST AIRCRAFT HERE,
INCLUDING STRATEGIC BOMBERS
CAPABLE OF CARRYING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
>> THE EFFORT MOSCOW IS MAKING
TO UPGRADE ITS ARCTIC BASIS IS
MASSIVE, INSIDE THE MODERN
HOUSING COMPLEX, CALLED A TRUE
FOIL, THE AIR COMMANDER
CONFIRMS TO ME THAT EVEN RUSHES
DANGEROUS TO YOU 95 STRATEGIC
BOMBERS, EXPLAIN SOMEONE SIZE
THAT U.S. IS B-52 CAN OPERATE
AT THE AIRFIELD HERE.
>> OF COURSE THEY CAN, HE SAYS,
HAVE A LOOK.
WE CAN LAND ALL TYPES OF
AIRCRAFT ON THIS BASE.
A CHILLING PROSPECT FOR THE U.
S. AND ITS ALLIES, CONSIDERING
FRIENDS USE OF LAND IS ONLY
ABOUT 160 MILES EAST OF NATO
TERRITORY.
THAT'S WELL WITHIN RANGE OF
THESE POWERFUL COASTAL DEFENSE
ROCKETS THE RUSSIANS ALSO
SHOWED US.
THEY'RE CAPABLE OF HITTING
SHIPS MORE THAN 200 MILES OFF
THE COAST, A THREAT THAT
WORRIES OF THE U.S..
>> WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT SOME
OF THE INCREASED MILITARY
ACTIVITIES IN THE ARCTIC, THAT
INCREASES THE DANGERS, THE
PROSPECTS OF ACCIDENTS, WE
CALCULATIONS.
>> THE MAIN REASON WHY THE
STANDOFF BETWEEN THE U.S. AND
RUSSIA IS HEATING UP IN THE
ARCTIC, IS CLIMATE CHANGE.
AS POLARIZE MELT, THE REGION IS
BECOMING MORE ACCESSIBLE AND
RUSSIA IS MOVING FAST TO STAKE
ITS CLAIMS.
MUCH OF THAT EFFORT IS LED FROM
HERE, THE HEADQUARTERS ON THE
NORTHERN FLEET AND A CLOSED
MILITARY TOWN, WHICH WE ALSO
GOT ASKED TO.
RUSSIA HAS BEEN UPGRADING ITS
FLEET FOR YEARS, HIS FLAGSHIP
IS THE PETER THE GREAT NUCLEAR
BATTLE CRUISER, OUTFITTED WITH
AN ARRAY OF WEAPONS TO HIT
TARGETS ON SEA AND LAND, TO
FIGHT OFF PLANES AND
SUBMARINES.
RUSSIA HAS A CLEAR STRATEGY
APPEAR IN THE ARCTIC,
ESSENTIALLY REVOLVES AROUND 3
DIFFERENT THINGS.
ON THE ONE HAND, A VERY STRONG
MILITARY.
THEN DOMINATE IN THE NORTHERN
SEA ROUTE, ALSO TAPPING AT
EXPLOITING NATURAL RESOURCES.
AND RUSSIA IS WARNING THE U. S.
AND ITS ALLIES, NOT TO MESS
WITH THAT PLAN.
>> IT HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY CLEAR
FOR EVERYONE FOR A LONG TIME,
THAT THIS IS OUR TERRITORY,
THIS IS OUR LAND.
WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR
ARCTIC COAST TO BE SAFE,
EVERYTHING THAT OUR COUNTRY
DOES THERE IS ABSOLUTELY
LEGITIMATE.
>> RHETORIC THAT INCREASINGLY
HAS THE U.S. AND RUSSIA ON A
COLLISION COURSE IN THE HIGH
NORTH, WITH MOSCOW SO FAR IN A
STRONGER POSITION.
ONE OF THE REASONS FOR THAT,
ROSEMARY, THE RUSSIANS HAVE
MADE THE ARCTIC A PRIORITY FOR
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS NOW.
A STRATEGIC UNIFIED MILITARY
COMMAND ABOARD THE NORTHERN
REGIONS ARE AND THEY SAY
THEY'VE CONSTRUCTED, IN THE
PAST COUPLE OF, YEARS AROUND
500 MILITARY SITES IN THAT
REGION.
ALL OF, THAT A BIG CONCERN FOR
THE UNITED STATES AND YET
ANOTHER SIGN, ROSEMARY,
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT ON YOUR SHOW SO MUCH AS
WELL.
HOW GLOBAL WARMING IS
INCREASINGLY LEADING TO
CONFLICT AROUND THE WORLD.
ROSEMARY.
>> ABSOLUTELY, THANKS